- [Tutor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk more about
inflation and deflation,
which we've talked about in other videos,
but we're gonna talk
about it in the context
of who benefits and who gets hurt,
especially in a situation where people
are lending money to each
other at fixed rates,
so let's set up a little scenario here.
So let's say that this is today
and this is in one year,
so in one year
and today I need my teeth
cleaned, it's an emergency,
but I don't have money to clean my teeth,
it costs 100 dollars and
you're my okay friend
and you say "Yes, you do
need your teeth cleaned,
"I will lend you 100 dollars,
"but I want to charge some interest,"
so today from my point of view,
I am going to borrow, I am going to borrow
100 dollars from you, my okay friend
and in a year I have to pay back,
you're gonna charge me 10% interest,
so I'm gonna have to pay back,
pay back
110 dollars.
Now let's think about some
different scenarios on inflation,
so let's imagine a world,
where there's no inflation,
so let's say today is my base period,
where the CPI is 100
and let's imagine that
the actual basket of goods
in our country is actually 100 dollars,
it'll help us visualize
things a little bit more
and let's say we have no inflation,
so in one year, the CPI,
that basket of goods
is still 100 dollars,
so in real terms and in future videos,
we'll talk more about
real and nominal terms,
but in real terms, you could
buy 10% more with 110 dollars,
than you could with that 100 dollars,
so you really got a real 10% return,
but now let's imagine a scenario
with a little bit of
inflation, a reasonable amount,
where in our base here, our CPI is 100
and then in a year, maybe
we've had 2% inflation,
so now our Consumer Price Index is 102,
well in this scenario, you're now,
and especially if we
view that basket of goods
as actually costing 100
dollars in the first year
and then 102 dollars one year
later, as we've talked about,
that's not always going to be the case,
in fact in most countries,
it's not that you could actually buy
that basket of goods for 100 dollars,
the 100 is usually just to be indicative,
but this is to help us make things
a little bit more tangible.
In this world, you're going to be able
to buy more than a basket
of goods, but not 10% more,
you're going to be able to buy
a little bit less than 8% more
and then we can set up a scenario,
where we have fairly extreme inflation
and this will make things very clear,
where our CPI goes from 100
to let's say that price
is more than double,
so let's say we go to
a world, where our CPI,
so this would be pretty extreme inflation,
where our CPI goes to 220.
So this is really interesting,
because in right now at the present,
what you are lending me,
that's equivalent to the basket of goods,
I could actually buy the
basket of goods there,
while in year one, what
I'm paying back to you,
you could only buy half a basket of goods
and so you lent me money
and even though nominally
it looks just superficially
like you're getting 10%
more in terms of dollars,
you can buy half as much
with that 110 dollars
as you could have bought a
year ago with that 100 dollars,
so in this world, even
though it looks like
you're getting a 10% nominal return,
your real return is pretty bad,
your real return is negative 50%,
you can buy half as much
with what you're getting
paid back as what you originally lent
and so the general trend here
is when you are in an
inflationary environment,
especially when the inflation
is more than expected,
oftentimes the interest rate
will bake in some inflation,
people will expect some
inflation in the interest rate,
but in general, inflation is going to,
the more inflation you have,
if you think about it
from my point of view,
I borrowed something where
I could have bought the basket of goods,
if you imagine the basket of goods
actually costs 100 dollars
and I'm paying back something,
where that would only buy
half a basket of goods,
you could even imagine
with that 100 dollars,
I buy a basket of goods
and then a year later,
I sell that basket of
goods for 220 dollars
and then I only have to pay half
of that 220 dollars back to you
and so I wouldn't have
got my teeth cleaned
in that situation,
but I would have been able
to profit from that thing
and so inflation,
especially when it's more
than expected inflation,
it benefits borrowers at fixed rates,
benefits borrowers
at fixed rates
and I keep saying at fixed rates,
because it's possible
that your interest rate
might somehow be pegged to inflation,
in which case it might
not benefit you so much
and it hurts lenders, it hurts lenders
at fixed rates.
Now as you can imagine,
deflation is going to be the opposite
and to make this very clear,
I'll make a very extreme
deflationary scenario.
Imagine we go from a CPI of 100
to a CPI,
CPI of 55
and if we literally view
that same basket of goods,
that would have cost 100 dollars
only costs 55 dollars now, think about it,
I am borrowing equivalent
of a basket of goods
and then I'm paying back to
you two baskets of goods,
110 dollars would buy two
baskets of goods in a year
and so in this deflationary scenario,
in this deflationary scenario,
you are actually getting,
even though nominally,
it looks like you're getting a 10% return,
the lender's getting a 10% return,
the real return, they're
getting 100% return,
they're able to buy twice as much
with what they get back,
than what they lent
and so this deflation hurts
borrowers at fixed rates,
hurts borrowers
at fixed rates
and it helps, and it helps lenders,
lenders at fixed rates.